there's a girl over here that just came
into the game
she don't know nothing she's scared
and she got this tight [ __ ] and she got
these
perky tits and and she's trying to
figure this out for the first time and
she
and your man come around and be like
baby i got some money for you can you
give me an experience
that i never had he still loves you
though
he appreciates you though he's gonna
give you the house
the car the credit but he just he's just
a man
he's just a man
all right diamond oh wait i ain't even
ready i got the cup on
go drink it up okay like i got a little
bit of
[ __ ] what are you drinking um
well i decided to try
dark liquor because white liquor i don't
know it's a bit not been agreeing with
my stomach
so i'm trying do say you do you drink
pretty much every time you go to work
oh i have to you have to i have to
because if i don't drink i'm in there
like
but it's like how do i talk to people
how do i interact how do i do this
because
this is all new for me um
how long you been doing this it's going
on three years
and three years it's fairly new for you
it's a little different for me my story
is a lot different
how did you get into it had to survive
baby
that's a common story i had to survive
and
let me take this last week and we gonna
get into it
you meet a guy for the first time
okay yeah he's cool he got money i don't
care about that
me you have to dismiss certain things
when it comes to a man
you have to dismiss it like what oh hey
he got a big chain
boom he got a big rat
he's gonna come in talking about some
baby i got all these racks
i can give you this i can give you that
what you own
i'll be like okay babe that's cool
that's nice okay great okay
i can give you 1500 for the night
pop it open let me see you okay
okay okay you about to
okay all right i'm down i'm cool
[ __ ] take off his drawers can i curse
of course
oh cuz i didn't know because you know
you two be a weird real right here yeah
say what you want
no okay you do it how you want you you
you know hollywood man
but [ __ ] wanna pop it up talking about
something
and man all the time the minute you
start trying to [ __ ] me raw
i devalue you i devalue you cause i'ma
stop you and say oh no baby
let's use protection and i don't care
how drunk i am
one thing i'm gonna make sure i'm about
my bread
and about my protection but i really
should say
this about my protection first i'm about
my protection
first it's about me
because this is the money so i gotta
protect it everywhere possible i don't
give a [ __ ] if i know you for three
years
we're using a condom every [ __ ] time
because the same way a guy has eyes for
me he has eyes for the next
the next the next
and all that nexus that he done
collected
he's going to put inside of me and i
don't want to risk that
i ain't been out here like that but i
have never had
an std i've never had an std
but i will say this there's been times
i've been running to the clinic like
please god help me i don't know
i don't know i don't know please help me
help you please
i don't know and i don't throw all my
money down terrible stress
and i'll talk about that later i don't
talked about it before
but if i've been spared this long
i gotta protect it because i made a
promise to god that was like
please god if you protect me this
one time i ain't never gonna [ __ ] up
i ain't never gonna [ __ ] up and it's the
most realest [ __ ] that i have and that's
why every time i'm like oh no baby you
gotta wear a condom
and then [ __ ] men
they'd be like oh okay yeah i'm gonna
wear a condom
and you gotta pick up on certain things
like
okay this is how they love to get you
from the back from the back this is how
[ __ ] look to get you because that's
how
the [ __ ] has tried to get me not once
but twice
the first time they really got me that's
how i learned my lesson
they was like okay let me get it from
the back okay cool
but then i hear
and that's them taking off the condom
and me i don't care i don't drink that
much but i drink enough to know my limit
whereas like i still have my senses you
gotta still
have your senses in this game and i'll
talk about this a little later you gotta
have your senses in this game
it was like and i looked down i said
baby i see the tipio dick what's up
and you start acting up and a dude
who's rock hard he ain't gonna
jeopardize
leaving on blue balls and that's how you
got em
that's how you got em because you gotta
play that game
the same way they trying to do you these
[ __ ] i don't care
these men i don't care how
clean how smell good they is how rich
they got it
how big of a chain if they dirty
that [ __ ] don't mean nothing if they're
dirty that [ __ ] don't mean nothing
you cannot let no man put
no disease on you because if this is
your money you should do
everything possible to protect that you
should
because if you got herpes how you gonna
[ __ ] the next [ __ ] who won't offer you
10 bands to [ __ ] wrong
he ain't gonna want to [ __ ] with you
after you give him that disease
he ain't gonna [ __ ] with you cause me
i never had no std not in my past life
before i was a dancer and not even as on
my dancer
the only thing if you [ __ ] or you
[ __ ]
out here really want to know
a yeast infection but any girl can get
that just by
coughing any girl can get that
but if this is your money if your body
is your money
then you should protect that like
this is a house this is equity you
should treat your [ __ ]
like it's credit because if it's credit
and it can make you more money
why are you gonna risk it for a [ __ ]
who dirty who want to [ __ ] 10 [ __ ]
and he don't know because men
they don't care you'd be surprised how
many men have tried to turn me over and
said baby bust it open
and they're not coming at me with no
condom i'm the one with the condom
i know what i can use latex baby i can't
use that
that's gonna give me a yeast infection i
don't play with that [ __ ]
it's gonna hurt me you gotta do what's
best for you
if a guy comes at you with money or he
makes it clear that he has money
oh okay that's cool that's fine you know
because i'm not talking about safe sex
anymore i'm talking about just a guy in
your life
romantically personally if a guy has
money does that mean something to you or
or is it usually trouble it don't mean
nothing to me because
me already in the mode this is how i am
oh you got money
okay cool that's fine all right babe i
would like this i would like that
all right cool that's great that's fine
that's cool that's fine all right great
that's all cool that's all fine but me
in the background
in my head this is how i am
all right how low does this guy go
what's his problem what is his fix
is he a pill head does he like drugs is
he a drug addict
is he an alcoholic what's his problem
how can i protect myself so i don't get
too
[ __ ] up in what the [ __ ] he got going
on
and this is where i start going like
okay
if he cool i gotta play the game but not
be so close to him
because at the end of the day you met me
in the strip club
i know you're tricking but i don't know
how bad you tricking
i don't know if you [ __ ] ten holes
raw and you trying to [ __ ] with me
i can't be the one if you [ __ ] ten holes
raw
i gotta be the same one i gotta be the
smart one
i gotta be the one that uses the game
good enough so i can excel higher
because i can't drag you i can't drag
myself down with you
what the [ __ ] what you doing and that's
just
what it is so you got to use that for
what it is
but you got to be smart you got to
protect
your prize you got to protect your heart
your mental
yeah you could get your heart broke [ __ ]
it oh well in 30 days
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
meet somebody else you're gonna forget
about the old one
but let's say you [ __ ] this one and
you got sick
yeah you take some antibiotics
but you always gonna have that oh i was
sick you're gonna have that stain on you
and you don't want that was the last
time you were in love oh the last time i
was live oh
probably not 60 days ago today today's
friday
yeah exactly it worked like that that's
how it'd be
that's how it would be well i can't even
say 60 days ago like
90s 90 days 90 days
this is the guy you met in the club
exactly i met him in the club
i mean do you meet guys outside of the
club ever
are you working so much i would say just
recently because there's a way to do
that
so you don't have to be in the club as
often you can meet guys
outside the club just by being a
presentable woman
and being by a presentable beautiful
woman
sorry i'm trying to make this very
pg as possible for
the rated r mental that's out there
you'll get demonetized
not where you're going you get the
monitor oh i don't want you to get three
more times i get demonetized all the
time it's okay [ __ ] it
man this is real talk youtube cannot
censor the real life
but um no let me finish it
what was your childhood like you had
both mom and dad
um my childhood i don't know how to
explain my childhood other than that
i was sheltered but between
i guess from the time that i was born
all the way up until i was 24
i dealt with abuse and the type of abuse
that i dealt with
was a lot of verbal abuse from my father
sheltering i grew up as jehovah witness
so it was a lot of sheltering
a lot of different things that i didn't
understand at the time
and it was very different
my father it wasn't until like years
later as i got older
i realized that he suffered from a
mental illness
that kind of was the reason why he was
the way he was
my mom she came from haiti
and not to really
develop her situation because she told
me never to speak about it
but when you're coming to this country
for the first time
you don't have any papers you don't have
any means of making any money you have
to do
what this person says to do
and as quickly as she came here she
became pregnant with my sister
and two years later she became pregnant
with me
and after she became pregnant with me
that's when things started to change
and she had to move in the direction
that her life was changing um
and that's kind of where it come from
there how is your dad mentally ill
in your opinion um i want to say that
now as i've gotten older and i'm 30 now
i believe he suffered from a type of
schizophrenia
um my family
and even in my culture mental illness
is not something that is a knowledge
mental illness is something seen as it's
a spirit it's a voodoo it's just
something that someone cursed you with
it's a magical
mythical thing and that's just
from the background but
being in america it's like hey there's
medication
there's therapy there's treatment for it
and as i've gotten older i understand
that
and i've accepted that do i love my
father
no do i want to rekindle a relationship
with him
no it's just i've accepted it
and it is what it is if i swear to see
my father like right there
i wouldn't feel any kind of way because
i've made so much peace with that
it's like i don't know him anymore he's
he made me and thank god that i'm here
so i can be somebody for my mom because
my mom is present
i had to make peace with the decisions
that my mom has made
because she put up with a lot of [ __ ]
that my dad had did that she should have
stood up for me
and been like hey this isn't right you
can't do this you can't do this you
can't be
x y and z and i had to make peace with
that i had to forgive my mom
and we have a stronger relationship now
because it's like it's not your fault
you came here you didn't know any
english you didn't know anybody you
didn't have
any family nobody it was just you
and you had to do the best you could to
survive
and that's the mentality i always have
you have to survive
you have to do what you can to survive
because nobody is going to do this [ __ ]
for you
and she had to do it she had one and
then two kids
and that's it so the abuse from your dad
was mostly verbal
not sexual very verbally abusive very
controllable verbally abusive
my dad he was verbally abusive the first
abuse started with
not only was it started with my mom it
started with my mom because that's all
she had at the time she didn't have any
kids
the verbal abuse started with my mom
very abusive
and she had to take it because she's in
a country
that she doesn't know anybody she
doesn't have any family
and this is the only person that she can
rely on
she came here illegally you can cut that
part out
i don't i don't want to dispel her
information
but she came here and my dad was all she
had
this one person that she relied on for
money
for guidance in the united states
she needed that relationship she had to
do what she had to do
to keep it going so
you know she made right she got pregnant
with my sister
my dad was upset that it was a girl but
she still kept that relationship going
she put up with the abuse she put up
with the verbal abuse
it wasn't physical but it was mostly she
doesn't know anything she doesn't know
america
she doesn't know america she doesn't
speak english she's relying on this
one person coming to america was a big
deal it was a big deal
and especially not to fully speak about
it but the way that she came here she
could have died
she could have died and she didn't want
to go back to that
and she knew that being out here she
didn't want to go back to haiti she
didn't want to go back to that life
she didn't want to go back to what she
she grew up in
have you been to haiti yes i've been
haiti a few times
what do you think of it oh
i'm not one of those spoiled haitians
regardless of the light-skinnedness
because there's a stigma
that you're light skinned that you're
you're up here
you're great you're you're fondly
looked upon oh no all i know in haiti
is the bottom all i know is haiti all
i've ever seen in haiti
was the bottom people with their belly
buttons out
no clothes no shoes living by the beach
washing themselves with salt water
mothers
struggling making mud pies that's all i
know that's all i've ever seen haiti
i don't know this nice side of haiti
that people keep talking about and
vacationing too
i don't know that side i've never seen
it i wish i have
but i've never seen it i don't know this
side so you're happy to be in america
oh yeah i'm happy to be in america and
i'm like damn i wish i would have been
somebody i could have been
well and and when you being haitian
you're supposed to be like a nurse a
doctor a lawyer
something up there i ain't been none of
that [ __ ] child i'm a stripper
i'm trying to make this i gotta make
this live song little piece
but it's like me seeing haiti i
never i know there's a nice side i know
there is
but i've never seen it i've never seen
it
and it just has to do with
the way my family came from because we
didn't grow up with that nice side
i don't know what it's like to see a
mansion
in haiti with running water all i know
was the well
yeah are you so would you describe
yourself as a happy person oh yeah
you're grateful you're happy i'm
grateful i'm happy i try to be
as positive life hasn't always been
super easy i would say from the time i
was born
till about the age of
27 i've really had to deal with abuse
and it's not so much punching hitting
abuse comes in all forms and it wasn't
until i got a little older
someone explained it to me that was like
that's abuse that's abuse i'm like
really
i was abused i didn't know
i didn't know because it was just like
dang i know life sucks but i didn't know
what's up this bad
and i felt like oh but other people have
it worse than me
but verbal abuse control
trauma all that stuff it is abuse i
still
even until this day don't even try to
acknowledge it i just have accepted it
and moved on
because what i want in my life is to be
happy to be positive
if it can help somebody you know
understand and understand like
hey this was abuse this just saying
something you should deal with
and cool then that's fine but even until
this day i still have
i still have like a hard time accepting
that this was abuse that i've went
through and i've went through it not
only
between my family between religion and
then a relationship
it's like it's hard it's like dang i've
been abused for over 10 years of my life
do you have kids no no kids you've been
married
no you didn't love that even
you had a long relationship at some
point yeah i had a long relationship but
left it was about four years
and that was abusive too as well so
it's like right after i got out of my
parents house
which was abusive
i looked at this man as like oh you're
finally my savior
and i well i didn't know it was like a
worse mistake
but i moved in
to his place and was like okay you're
going to now be my protector
you're going to now be my savior and
we're going to work together and build
something
that's going to be great it's going to
be better
it's going to be something that
different from what i'm used to
but now you're my abuser you're verbally
abusing me
and you're verbally abusing me because
you're addicted to alcohol
you're i can't even call weed or drug
even to this day but it's like you have
to smoke and drink
every night and when you drink because
that's the more
higher i guess the higher drug
you're taking that out on me you're
being verbally abusive to me
and the last kind of year of the
relationship it became
i became more distant i became more
reserved i became more
trying to put my foot down and his
advances towards me
became okay you're withholding
from me so i'm gonna force myself on you
it is what it is and i just know i had
to get out of it
and i had to plot my escape out of it
is that where stripping kind of came
into the picture
to survive that's where that's where it
started
tell me about stripping tell me about
working in this strip club
what was it like what do you want to
know about working this will you tell me
baby because
i got a whole story for you baby
where do we start what about the guys
what what what a girl
girlfriends and wives need to know about
their
partners when they go to strip clubs
first of all
you can't be slacking there's no baby
mama
there's no girlfriend that's of that
[ __ ]
i'm sorry baby but you gotta understand
your man is a man and man have
needs even though
he [ __ ] with you ain't enough
you got loose skin your titties is down
here
yo no [ __ ] ain't that tight
listen your [ __ ] ain't that [ __ ]
tight
it ain't that [ __ ] tight [ __ ] is
tired
you know let's and [ __ ] be sitting
here like damn
i'm trying to be safe oh
[ __ ] yo [ __ ] loose your skin loose
[ __ ] it he going to the strip club he's
going to look for [ __ ] that are
they on that
[ __ ] [ __ ] they're looking for hoes they
looking for
[ __ ] that do all kind of weird [ __ ]
this [ __ ] want fingers he want to stick
his fingers here
he want to stick his dick here he want
to do all kind of freaky [ __ ]
that's what your husband want to do and
you're not giving it to him
and you can't you got this this this
flappy whatever the hell that doctor
gave
you you got too many scars up over here
you got too many and that's not to
devalue you as a woman
but it's like baby this is what you have
there's a girl over here that just came
into the game
she don't know nothing she's scared
and she got this tight [ __ ] and she got
these
perky tits and and she's trying to
figure this out for the first time
and she and your man come around and be
like
baby i got some money for you can you
give me an experience
that i never had
he still loves you though he appreciates
you though
he gonna give you the house the car the
credit
but he just he's just a man he's just a
man
and he have needs that need to be
experienced
even if it's just for one night what
night
just one night baby and he gonna make
this girl
whether it be for five hundred dollars
or a thousand dollars
or 10k he just want to experience
something different
than what you can offer him it doesn't
devalue you
as a woman but it's like damn
this man just want to have a
different kind of time than what you can
offer him at that moment and that's it
it's nothing more it's nothing less
it's just for one night and that's all
you gotta understand
it's just for one night just for one
night
and he gonna give it to this girl he
gonna let her
do what she got to do he's gonna feel
how he gonna feel
he's gonna feel good he's gonna be like
damn i don't did this
he gonna brag to his homeboy
he's gonna grab too he's gonna brag
to his homies in jail doing
20 years so uh tell me about the the
white clubs
okay so with the white clubs you have to
understand
in the white clubs it's more based off
of
conversation and emotion because these
guys coming in
they got their girlfriends bitching at
them
they got their wives bitching at them
they used to seeing
loose skin
attitude
all kind of whatever irritant
whatever makes a man mad you know
that's what they used to seeing but when
they come into the white club
they're looking for a hey
how's it going baby
my name is iron
you seem a man stressed
what can i do to make your night better
i know that you're tired
i know that you're stressed
but i want to make that like better for
you
would you like me
you like me sloppy
would you like me to keep it cute
you tell me baby i'm here for you
i'm here for you baby
i want to make tonight good for you
that's okay
what's what is just about
what's all your stress about babe don't
be shy with me
i'm here for you
you just let me know what your fairness
is about
because you never know
i can make it all happen
better tell me baby
do you like head
oh my god but that's how it be
because i notice more in we're just
gonna say caucasian club
it's more of a a need
it's it's more of a what they're not
getting at home
that they can find and where are you
working tonight the white club or the
black club
tonight oh and the white floor maybe
yeah it's friday
i think i'm going to meet you there
right is due right is
right is doom right is
dude
and the what are the black clubs like
black club
is don't get me wrong within the white
club
during the week is very very slow
so me i don't know if i got like 80d
or something like that like
i like to be stimulated in my head
in the white club during the week you
can find
a good trick and what i mean by trick
which is
and [ __ ] you don't have to say a man
could i curse
sure you a man you don't have to say too
much to
you you you got demonetized in the first
minute so i don't think oh baby
you you can let
but like in the first you know
the first couple conversation you know
you have to understand
men they want different things but you
have to also remember
what you want out of these men because
a man that came into my life
i never women okay women in the black
club
we very bougie we very [ __ ] oh he
don't look like he don't spend a hundred
dollars
we ain't gonna talk to him
and i know i'm being real dramatic but
this is what the mental is
this is what the mental is but that man
that you know
and i know i'm being over dramatic but
that's how i have to be
because some of you girls out there
don't
[ __ ] know that same man that you
that man because this is what happened
to me
baby look at me bring that camera close
because that's what i want to know
that's
same man that's same man
that's same man oh baby
oh that's same man when i got him
that same man when i got him he don't
give me a whole 10
bands 10 bands and for the people that
who don't understand what
10 bands is is 10
000 cold dollars
cash if you don't change my whole
[ __ ] life my whole
[ __ ] life because what you don't see
is
because as good as i look as nice as
these things are
as good as this buddy is as soft as
it is
as soft that is
baby come here come here real close
because i want [ __ ] to
understand the [ __ ] was
struggling living in the projects
and i looked as good as it looked but
until i started using that game
that it was meant for that's when i
started coming up so unless you finna do
the same
then [ __ ] you just struggling like the
rest of these [ __ ]
so people can call it tricking [ __ ]
for money
this that in the third but at the end of
the damn day
if you got a note on your door saying
that if you don't pay this damn rent
within 30 days
then what the [ __ ] you got what the [ __ ]
you got
you gotta start using the game
for what you need and it just is what it
is
it just says what it is
it how you want it don't work the same
way for every girl
but i'm just telling you that
if you have a goal in mind if you see
yourself
more than just the club
you gotta start manifesting what you
want
if you see yourself
i don't know in the business
in the meetings with the millions for
properties
for i don't know let's say you want to
do jewelry
then you got to finesse for that what
you over here with these bags and shoes
for that [ __ ] ain't gonna let you
nowhere
you gotta get in these meetings you
gotta understand
what this game can get you because these
[ __ ]
is dumb as [ __ ] [ __ ] is dumb as [ __ ]
but they're not too dumb they'll let you
know enough
to eat with them but you gotta do enough
so you can sit with them and be a boss
and any real [ __ ] who understand what
the [ __ ] i'm saying
you gonna make sure that you be a boss
any [ __ ] who really about that life you
won't be a boss
you won't be a boss it ain't about
[ __ ] for bags and shoes of a
vacation vacations is nothing more than
an instagram picture
ain't nothing bored just for clout i
don't care about no clout
you can make clout at any point in time
you gotta make something that you can
eat
your kids can eat your mom can eat
and after your mom pass away that your
praying kids can eat you can eat
you gotta eat long term you gotta have
that
money that can do something for you
today tomorrow for your grandkids for
your ancestors
for this that and the third you gotta
make a legacy you gotta
hold stuff you gotta own stuff you gotta
own [ __ ]
i don't own stuff at one point in my
life people always ask me
oh diamond how you got your body done
how you got your body done
the real [ __ ] that's gonna take you
somewhere you wanna get a body like this
baby you gotta invest in real estate
this body
this titty this ass came from real
estate
real estate can you say it with me
real estate that means investing
in a property and you might not see
it might be a short-term lease
short term but if you stay in there a
year
and you make the right investment when
it's time for you to sell that [ __ ]
you'd be surprised how much your money
you get back
and you'd be like damn this is the thing
that i always go back and forth with
i still have
like a complex was it worth the abuse
to look like this
or could i have made it a different way
because that's the track that i'm on i
gotta make it a different way
i don't wanna deal with the abuse i
don't wanna deal with being yelled at
i don't want to be deal with getting
raped i don't want to deal with getting
talked down as a woman i want to be
seen as damn she's strong
she have knowledge she knows what she
doing
she she's not gonna fall for the little
stuff
i wanna i want people to respect
that damn yeah she been through some
stuff
but she know better now versus back then
which was
like yeah you got right for this yeah
you got yelled at for this
yeah you you lay down for this
because all that [ __ ] led me to where
i'm
at today so some of the girls coming up
you gotta ask yourself
can you do the same thing and you can't
you can't deal with a man yelling at you
when you're drunk you can't deal with
a man yelling at you when you have no
money in your bank account
you can't even make it to work with no
money
your card when you swipe to get gas to
get to where you [ __ ] getting to
is saying decline insufficient funds
and you don't got nothing to do you
don't have no [ __ ] to do
do you take your chances on that less
than half a tank
to drive our way to a job or do you go
back home
what the [ __ ] do you do and when you
quit that man
and say [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
you're like okay i'mma go
throw my ass in the club and see what it
do and when you first
do what it do you don't make the money
you don't make the money that you're
making you don't make the money
because you don't know the game you
don't know the people
you don't know what the [ __ ] you doing
you just out here like
oh i just wait and see you waiting in
the back
but you waiting in the back so you can
study the game
and understand okay this is who i get to
this is who i get to this is who i get
to and that's the way the game is
so how does this work affect you
emotionally
emotionally um i am never gonna lie
it do give me anxiety it made me
hard to trust people i'd be feeling like
yeah i'd be getting depressed
but it made me like on some flip [ __ ]
like okay what this person want
do they do they want to try to trick me
alcohol is how you deal with that
yeah alcohol to deal with it because
it's like
i gotta suppress that thinking
because if i don't think like that if i
don't have the alcohol
in me it'll make me like cool
sedated calm down because if i don't
have the alcohol
i just be in there with a mean face like
okay what the [ __ ] was first of all okay
that's helping just a
third because i always be thinking like
how they finna get me
how they finna run down the alcohol
listens you up opens you up
yeah it opens me up enough to be
flirtatious
sexual uh more flirtatious
to an extent but if i don't have that
alcohol in me
i'm just very frigid very cold and i'm
really really
myself and the way that i'm really
myself is just like
that's how i am i'm very frigid i'm very
cold
because i can't be as open and loose
that i need to be
and when you're a dancer you have to be
flirtatious
very sexual very like very enticing like
hey
i'm cool i'm good for a down time and
you have to look like you play that
sexual part
and i can't play that part unless i have
liquor
i can't play that part unless i have
liquor and i'm
i'm not sorry to nobody what the [ __ ]
y'all owe me what the [ __ ] y'all owe me
nothing
but some money and that's the way that
it is that it is
but i have to drink in order to suppress
that and i have to control it
and i hope people understand that you
have to have a balance
in this game you have to have a balance
because if you don't have a balance
you're going to fall for anything
because [ __ ] don't try to drug
me
kill me set me up all kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i don't have to survive that
and you don't have to have that [ __ ]
with you and you have to
you have to it's the game but
that's the way that i have to be you
have to be a little flirtatious so you
can make your money
you don't have to be a little you know a
little open you know
a little a little sexual
and that's just the way it is for the
game for your job to make the money
but anything outside of that [ __ ] that
talk [ __ ] talking about come with me
here this that in the third
ain't none of that ain't none of that
unless you got that piece with you
all right thank you so much for an
interesting talk
thank you you're fascinating thank you
we're going to have to do a part two one
day
hopefully all right thank you thank you
you